it's my birthday and Mama sharp here has
some secrets that I really wish someone
had shared with me sooner probably would
have saved me a lot in therapy right
pops
[Music]
yeah super quick jump in here I need to
tell you about my sponsor today element
so you guys have heard me talk about
element for a while now but it's a
product I was using well before I
started start working with them and I
obviously still love it today it was
great when I was breastfeeding essential
for when I play tennis in the Heat and
it helps with keeping my electrolytes
balance that some of my medications tend
to throw off a lot of my colleagues in
Sports Nutrition also swear by element
specifically because it has a science
backed electrolyte ratio of 1,000 Mig
sodium 200 Mig potassium and 60 Mig
magnesium and it has no colors sugar or
fillers I'm still a fan of the mango
chili it's always been my fav I love the
heat but they have nine different
flavors and they are nail launching
their element chocolate medley for the
cool weather months ahead so there's
chocolate raspberry chocolate mint and
chocolate chai which I'm sure is going
to come in handy for ski season up here
in Canada the medley is only available
for a limited time only so if you love
The Salty sweet chocolate flavors you're
going to want to stock up right now
element is offering my viewers a free
sample pack with any order so that's
eight single serving packets for free
with any element order this is a really
great way to try all eight flavors or
share element with a salty friend so get
yours at drink element.com
slabby and again this deal is only
available through my link so you've got
to go to d r i n KLM nt.com slabby sharp
to get yours but anyways is your
birthday girl Abby sharp welcome back to
my channel I'm going to be taking a
little slower today I got my coffee I
got my protein shake I got Poppy's
cheese her reward for not barking
throughout this because yeah it's my
birthday I'm an adult and I can do what
I want right yeah poppy loves that but I
am officially 36 years old today which
honestly feels like such an
anticlimactic age last year I had a big
party for 35 and I stayed in a hotel and
I did like a whole overnight thing with
my friends and no kids and I love that
cuz I've always been like a really big
birthday girl but no I'm keeping it
relatively lowkey this year even though
I also kind of feel like I have more to
celebrate now than ever before but you
know at 36 I really do think that I'm
probably at the best place in my life
this has been a really good year for me
and I don't necessarily mean MoneyWise
or career-wise even though there's a lot
of really exciting things in the
works but I just feel like I'm really at
peace with myself now my mind my body my
spirituality everything just kind of
seems like it's finally falling into
place I am double fisting it this
morning with the Beverages and I love
that for us I love it for us bow down to
percules but yeah I just really wanted
to share some secrets that I feel like
I've cracked the code on that helped me
get this place that I only wish I had
some insight into decades ago so
breakthrough number one poppy NOS this I
know this we both know this has really
been medicating for my mental health
honestly this has probably been one of
the most important action items that I
have taken for my health that's
literally impacted every area of my life
you know I really resisted psych
medication for so long despite suffering
from crippling insomnia I had an anxiety
disorder ocpd and as I recently learned
also ADHD which was undiagnosed for most
of my life and it would have been nice
to know that like a decade ago but as I
discussed in my video here about pill
shaming you know I was really scared to
go on medication because of the stigma
there's just such a toxic narrative in
the Wellness Community that food is
medicine and if you take it any drugs
you're like taking the easy way out
you're cheating you're not trying hard
enough and I have never taken the easy
way out of anything like so I just feel
like hard work and struggle has just
been the song I've always sang but
taking medication for my sleep and
anxiety has literally changed every
aspect of my life you know sleeping
better has helped improve my tolerance
for stressful situations it's improved
my marriage and other relationships it's
helped me be a more compassionate and
kind parent Maybe way more efficient at
my job it's helped improve my immune
system and gut health and help manage
cravings and even my set point weight
Etc dit for anxiety Mets there is no
aspect of my overall health picture that
hasn't in some way been improved by
these drugs honestly had somebody told
me when I was 20 that it's okay to take
a bill to quiet the obsessive thoughts
in my brain I am quite literally 100%
confident that I wouldn't have spent a
decade clawing my way out of a a
full-blown eating disorder and the years
of self-loathing that followed and this
is why I talk about my mental health
Journey you know I'm really trying to
destigmatized in hopes that it
encourages others to seek the help that
they need better or earlier than I did I
just feel like I wasted so much of my
important life now the second really big
breakthrough for me has been making
peace with not having a perfect diet my
20s were no doubt my worst era
emotionally and physically and a lot of
that was due to my struggle with
orthorexia you know I am admittedly a
perfectionist as I discussed in a lot
more detail in my video here and I spent
way too much of my time in the past
obsessing over diet Perfection you know
meeting specific grams of protein or
specific amounts of fiber Omega-3s or
specific calories or numbers portions
Etc and when it end up happening to me
and actually happens to a lot of people
with disordered eating or EDS like
orthorexia it literally just became too
uous for me to count up calories and
nutrients in every meal or different
meals every day so I basically just
ended up eating the exact same breakfast
lunch dinner snacks every single day
without any sort of variation whatsoever
I became terrified of changing things up
same fruit same cheese same chicken
couldn't even change a brand God forbid
an instaart Shopper couldn't find what I
ordered and maybe this also had to do a
little bit with the undiagnosed ADHD but
there was obviously also that orthorexia
opponent as well and there was nothing
intuitive about this like the only joy
that I would derive from food was during
a massive binge after eating chicken and
broccoli twice a day 7 days a week so
it's like i' be dragging myself through
salmon three times a week to meet my
Omega-3s and I never sto to ask myself
if I even like
salmon what did you say I said I don't
want to any damn salmon cuz I didn't
really but what I've learned over the
past decade is our diet does not need to
be perfect to thrive it definitely
doesn't need to be perfect every day our
bodies are so incredibly resilient and
if we're getting a variety of different
proteins and fats and Grains fruits and
veggies over time along with of course
enough calories we are very likely
meeting at least most of our nutrient
needs and when we don't just because you
know we've got preferences or
restrictions Etc supplements can be a
really great stand in so like I do my
protein shake most days a week because I
don't always feel like cooking protein
especially in the morning or even for
lunch sometimes if I'm super busy and I
take certain key vitamins like Omega-3s
every day because like I said I don't
want to eat salmon or trout all the time
not my favorite and you know as a
dietitian of course we are supposed to
be pushing for a food first approach to
nutrition and I just guessed that early
on in my career I took that Mantra way
too conservatively but I've been doing
this for a really long time now and I've
since learned that a carefully planned
supplement Reg can really help to take
the pressure off of needing that perfect
diet which just opens the door for food
freedom and just having a better more
relaxed relationship with food so yeah
once I better understood what foods I
like or don't like or feel good to me or
don't feel good to me as someone with
IBS for example of course also getting
regular blood work and working with my
own dietitian I've been able to better
understand a supplement regimen that
works for me which has done wonders for
my relationship with food as well and
speaking of of eating and you know what
feels good that is another huge 30-some
learning for me you know I feel like I
have finally learn how to respect my
body which in my 20s I would not have
even been able to touch not only did I
hate my body in my 20s and by
association hate myself every single
time I caught a glimpse of my body but I
had zero regard for its needs and what
felt good it's like I just wanted to
punish it in every way imaginable at
both extremes I was either eating an
entire pizza and a whole order of wings
and an ice cream sundae to the point of
sickness or I was starving myself on
just like a bowl of steamed vegetables
nothing about my relationship with my
body in my 20s was respectful and I'm
not saying that we should expect 20s
something year olds to eat like 30s
something year olds the kids can rally a
lot better than us they got faster
metabolisms they got faster recovery
from like less healthy behaviors Etc but
I just wish I had learned to respect my
body not love it not love it not think I
look snatched 24/7 but respect its basic
Primal needs like just respecting that
it felt better to eat an actual sandwich
than a salad with no dressing or
respecting that it felt better to have
dinner before a night out drinking than
to try to save calories for more shots
or respecting that it felt better to
have regular balanced meals throughout
the week rather than to starve ones for
6 days only to have a big binge that's a
respect issue to me that's not like an
age thing and I definitely feel like I
could have figured that out way earlier
on in life had I not been restricting
now at 36 years old I respect my body
enough to pay attention to how different
foods make it feel and if I do avoid
something I don't feel deprived because
it's from an act of self-care so like I
don't feel a huge desire to eat a big
piece of cake with ice cream and like
three sugary cocktails on a Tuesday
night because I know that physically
it's going to give me the I and I also
know that if I don't have vegetables at
dinner I'm not going to feel great the
next day things aren't going to be
moving so well down there this is data
that I've collected so I now can
intuitively make more nutritious choices
without there being this sense of
restriction and rebound binge because
ultimately I respect my body and I
really really wish I had figured this
out in my 20s poppy you are drooling all
over
me going to have to wash these jeans we
of to talk about exercise I have just
stopped doing exercise that I hate and
it is liberating you know in my 20s I
had I guess a lot more free time on my
hands because I didn't have kids I
didn't have a mortgage I didn't have dog
I didn't really have any major
responsibilities outside of myself and
the result is that I had set up this
expectation where I would drag myself
through a lot of strenuous exercise that
I legitimately hated I hated it
I would spin several times a week plus
do some kind of strength training
Fitness class I mean there was no
question I had an ere exercising problem
that was part of the Ed but it really
really really made me hate exercise for
a while because it just didn't feel good
for my body right like my body was fully
depleted but these days I've Got a Way
healthier relationship with movement
where I've literally just given up
anything and everything that I don't
like been inning bye running definitely
bye cuz there's no way I'm dragging
myself through a brisk walk when there's
a 99.9% chance I'm going to pee my pants
e your pants is cool consider me Miles
Davis but yeah I've just tried to
ReDiscover all the things about movement
that I love and I just refuse to drag
myself through if I don't so typically
this means I walk every day either
outside if I can especially cuz I've got
a dog so it definitely encouraged me to
do so or inside if it's not so great I
work with a trainer a few times a week
that I love and I just started taking up
tennis about a year ago which is great
cardio and also super duper fun and I
cannot wait to play with my boys one day
cuz they're loving it too it's like a
family thing for us now but yeah not
only is this amazing for my mental
health but I'm actually in much better
physical shape now at 36 after two kids
then I was in my 20s pre IVF in
pregnancy so despite what 20-some Abby
feared not burning a of calories through
exercise didn't suddenly make me gain a
of weight or become unhealthy that I
wish I knew right and finally and this
is probably the most important right
here right now I have stopped living for
other people's approval you know
struggling with your self identity and
self-confidence is kind of par for the
course in your 20s but I feel like a lot
of my struggle had has been related to
being told that I was different or
difficult you know there's lots of
labels that people have used to describe
people like me anxious too sensitive
unstable weird perfectionist Gladiator
temperament highly sensitive person
Orchid neurod Divergent gifted Etc and
in my childhood and teens and even young
adulthood most of the labels use
specifically for me to me have been the
ones with the more negative connotation
so it's like I don't get you so
therefore you must be crazy but this is
partially why the ADHD diagnosis was so
incredibly freeing for me I finally felt
like I understood my brain like I
understood that it could be used in
unique extraordinary ways and I finally
could look back on all those years of
being told that I was wrong with
compassion rather than just more
self-loathing and shame it truly opened
the doors for me to do do great things I
can see it in my work I can see it in my
mothering I can see it in my marriage
and I can definitely see it in my
physical and emotional health it's like
the rigidity in me that has held me back
for so many decades three decades has
softened because I don't have to be so
guarded I can put the cards on the table
and I can say proudly that this is who I
am and I love who I am and this
confidence means I'm not overanalyzing
every interaction reaction or going down
the shame spiral every single time a
troll says I'm stupid or I'm fat or I'm
ugly or something insu like oh I used to
like Abby Shar but now I find her
annoying and that doesn't mean I'm cocky
and it doesn't mean that I'm not open to
being wrong or changing the way I do
things based on feedback you guys know
I've always been very very open to your
feedback but it means that it took
literally 36 years to know my worth and
to love myself even through these
imperfections and little quirks and of
of course some of this
self-actualization has just come with
age I wouldn't expect 20-year-old me to
be this wise but I know I would have
suffered a lot less working in such a
public facing industry had I done more
psychological and spiritual work upfront
and that's asking a lot of 20-year-old
Millennial me but I hope that the work
that us Millennials and gen Z's have
done will benefit our kids Generations
so that maybe by the time that they're
getting to their 20s they're already a
lot more self-secure you know a lot of
people ask me what my goals are for my
kids and I think that they expect me to
say something about them oh I just want
them to be healthy and go to Harvard or
Oxford or meet a nice partner and have a
family or carry on the family business
Etc but it kind of just throws them off
a little bit when I literally just say I
want them to love who they are all their
little weird annoying quirks and all
because it's that strong sense of self
and self-confidence and self-worth that
I believe will bring in all those other
external markers of success I honestly
think 36 is going to be one of the
biggest and best years of my life so I
am very excited to take it all in and on
that note I'm going to finish my shake
CB's going to probably finish this
cheese and have a lot of diarrhea and
we're going to watch a Little Love is
Blind but I know a lot of New Year's
resolutions are coming up so I hope this
gives you a little inspiration for some
things to work on that doesn't revolve
around calorie restriction but I hope
you guys enjoyed this video definitely
leave me a comment below give it a
thumbs up don't forget to subscribe and
hit up my description for my three
hunger crushing combo ebook and I will
see you next time on aby's kitchen
bye